rooty of the strongest chemistry with
even just like kissing him there is just
like chemistry that is I mean it's just
undeniable and yeah there is a
definitely a physical attraction there
that accelerated in way faster and off
the charts who makes you cry the most
Lupita's all season long okay because
like Colton did you at any point come
close to walking away yes
when towards the end what can you tease
about what maybe makes you want to walk
away I mean I don't think there was like
a certain moment it was more just this
is hard this isn't gonna work
not as dramatic it's like it was more
like conversation of like I don't know
if this is gonna work for me
but I probably would have finished it
it's more like you don't know if you're
gonna wind up with someone yeah more
that way okay are you engaged I'm really
happy for the opportunity that I had and
I'm excited for everybody to see the
growth and what I learned and how my
experience Thank You president Hanna
what a good politically correct answer
[Music]